So just to recall where we're at, we started out taking a look at
histograms of inter-tweet times in order to get a feel for the data.
We observed that it seemed to follow an exponential distribution.
Now as we recall the form of an exponential distribution is
the following expression.
And so we did a maximum likelihood estimation fit for
this distribution to the observed data.
But the problem is,
how sure are we that the beta value we fit is the correct value?
And as we discovered, that confidence depends on the amount of data we have.
And we found that we could quantify that uncertainty via Chebyshev's inequality.
Which simply says that the absolute value of the deviation of our
estimate of beta from the actual value of beta, that the probability of
that being greater than epsilon is one over four n epsilon squared.
But there's actually a tighter bound on this confidence interval
via something called Hoeffding's inequality.
So Hoeffding's inequality is saying exactly the same sort of
statement about our estimate of the true beta parameter.
It's just talking about the probability that our deviation from the true data
parameter is greater than epsilon, but the bound on it is a little bit better.
Instead of one over four n epsilon squared,
it uses two times e to the power of two n epsilon squared.
A link to more about Hoeffding's Inequality is in the instructor's notes.
But again, as you can see,
the inequality depends on the amount of data that we've collected